non so se avete visto le storie che ho
fatto Dove hai risposto appunto a Come
sopravvivere al Natale le situazioni a
Natale che si creano quelle spiacevoli
Ecco diciamo che se voi incontrato un
parente che vi chiediamo quando vi
laureate quando mi fate
fidanzatino fidanzatine Ecco Potete
provare a dargli il panettone per farlo
stare zitto perché ho provato a
tirarglielo direttamente Magari magari
funziona potrebbe essere ma ci sono
anche altre situazioni ad esempio quando
giocato a tombola e non vincete troppo
neanche ad esempio un torneo per la
switch che tra l'altro Purtroppo da
quando avete un prezzo super vantaggioso
l'ammazzatore Cosa vuol dire questa cosa
e soprattutto ragazzi se vi regalano
pigiami calzini quanti cose così figo da
te c'è il buon Favij che ricicla regali
e li rivendo divento Quindi se mi fanno
schifo le manda te li rivendo per altri
consigli business Seguite il mio canale